I was wondering on I personally I'm a
progressive mm-hm and you know I was
just wondering with our current
political atmosphere right now why is it
that we have strayed away from not not
just right or left or just general
people in politics straight away from
facts and try to twist around the truth
for example like with at Fox MSNBC all
these big corporate news programs they
tend to have an agenda why is it that
it's so hard to get facts out to people
I mean I think it's always been hard to
get facts out to people as the truth I
think that narrative has always been
more prominent in our mind what we want
to believe I mean confirmation bias is
obviously a very prevalent thing what
you want to believe you tend to you tend
believe and you tend to look for excuses
to believe it I think that in the era of
mass media where every taste can be
catered to you see that a lot more often
obviously and so if you think like
Rachel Maddow you're likely to watch
Rachel Maddow if you think like Sean
Hannity you're likely to watch Sean
Hannity and have all your biases
confirmed that's one of the reasons why
I hope that I'm at least attempting to
present facts even some facts that
disagree with my position and then
explain why you know those are wrong and
if you present the fact to me that
disagrees with my position I'll
acknowledge the fact I'll either say
that it's trays for my framework or not
I mean it's something that I strive to
do maybe I fail but something I'm trying
to do I think that the reason that
people have strayed away from fact and
and moved into subjectivity is because
there's something comforting about
subjectivity you can never be wrong I
think that facts is that somebody can
prove you wrong it's uncomfortable to be
out there on the limo all the time
waiting for somebody who saw it off
behind you right doing what I do it's a
lot of fun I mean I love what I do for a
living
but I will also say that there's a
constant feeling of am i right and when
somebody says you're wrong you got a
gives you a good person you think well
maybe I am wrong let me examine that
more and it's uncomfortable to feel like
you're wrong every time you feel like
you're wrong it means you have to
examine your presuppositions and think
about whether you're sit you're saying
the right things and so I take criticism
seriously or at least I try to and I
think that that's that's a hard thing to
do and especially in an era where we
have been told that there's a virtue of
being offended that you being offended
is a substitute for you learning
something that if you don't like what
I'm saying
then you being offended is enough for
you to just dismiss it out of hand you
don't have to go home and do any
research that's made things very
for people particularly in everybody's
into virtue signaling now it's very easy
that this is why you see these kind of
tsunamis that start where people will
call Steven pink or racist
I mean Steven Pinker is a lefty Steven
Pinker only says that there are
differences in biology between men and
women for example or he'll say things
like I've said that there are different
crime rates in particular communities
and then he'll get blasted for this is
supposedly upholding all right views
that's because people want to believe
that those facts are not right and so
they will blame his motivation and then
in tribute to him a motivation they
doesn't like so if we can refrain from
questioning each other's motivation and
go to maybe where we'd go wrong in logic
then maybe could have a conversation
this by the way it's one of the reasons
why even though I'm an Orthodox Jew I
never cite the Bible in defense of my
positions because I know that a lot of
people don't believe in the Bible so we
can't have a conversation on common
ground here